[Music]
[Music]
so for me it's very very exciting to
have Carol with us today to help us kind
of puzzle out this whole question of
where the world seems to be going Carol
thank you I I will be talking not so
much about whether there's intelligent
life elsewhere but whether there's
intelligent life here I want to talk
mainly about the development of Science
and Technology and its consequences
I will make some economic statements
which if I'm extremely lucky will be as
as competent as Lester's Astrophysical
statements we are a tool using species
it's our our only hedge against disaster
our ancestors when they came down from
the trees ten million years ago or
something like that
we're not faster than the competition
not stronger than the competition not
better camouflage not better
diggers or swimmers or flyers or runners
all we had going for us was being
smarter having hands with which we could
build things and that has was and has
been the secret of our success we were
technological from the beginning so two
million years ago our ancestors had a
vast stone and wood technology we knew
how to chip and flake
carve and that's how we managed to make
a living in a very good living it was
that hunter-gatherer way of life spread
to all six continents existed for a
million years and the bulk of the
evidence is that most of those economies
had surpluses and that the amount of
time that people work in hunter-gatherer
societies even the paltry remnants that
are around today is less than the
fraction of time that people work in
modern industrial economies so
immediately there is a real question
about how much progress has been made in
the last million years the the critical
step in human history before the present
time is the domestication of plants and
animals the Agricultural Revolution of
roughly and the years ago
where it was figured out
instead of simply harvesting
vegetables and nuts
all by themselves
you could use generally in river valleys
natural irrigation
plant crops and therefore it is
in a small area than was otherwise
available
that meant that the previous way of life
ruff fault grieve his way
the hunter-gatherers was a nomadic
style of existence and if you're enough
and you follow the game
wander you carry your possessions on
your back along with your children
and that means you
possessions
societies
virgin
personal property
no sense of owners
the game is
is shot
is distributed
to lots of people
among the mmm can't say exactly but you
gotta do that and simultaneously
Republic of Botswana the praise belongs
not the person who shot it but the
person who made the arrow
a very different kind of lifestyle which
it's very interesting badminton spend
much time on it but what I'd like to
stress is that human beings have spent
something like 99% of the history in an
extremely different kind of social
situation extremely different kinds of
economic situation but a very familiar
kind of technological situation to what
we have today and to the extent that we
have emotional predispositions that are
hereditary a lot of them must be geared
to those hunter-gatherer at times and
find very little expression in modern
industrial economies now
after the settled agricultural
revolution it was clear that you had to
organize large numbers of people over
large areas along the Nile or the
Yangtze this required a political
organization that had never been seen
before it involved hierarchical
political structures which don't exist
in any untogether society on the planet
it involved enforcement police armies
which are extremely rare among
hunter-gatherers it involved slavery
unknown others we are living in the last
ten thousand years in an extremely
anomalous circumstance for the history
of the human species now the technology
has been monotonically developing always
for short-term advantage it's extremely
rare that a technological development is
forsworn because a hundred years from
now we can see that there will be some
serious negative consequences even
though ten years from now we can see
that there will be some significant
advantage we never think on those on
those timescales 100 years from now
we'll be dead someone else is watching
let them look out for that
well this passion for the short term
over the long term
coupled with extraordinary technological
prowess as I maintain produced a an
extremely dangerous and critical
circumstance at the present time the
technology now permits us to affect the
entire planet and so apart from the
evident economic interdependence of the
planet
which Lester so brilliantly discussed
just a moaning on there is an enormous
technological interdependence and I'd
like to give a few examples the innocent
act of burning fossil fuels coal peat
wood natural gas petroleum products has
consequences it seems the most natural
thing in the world the global economy is
geared mainly on the fossil fuels but
every time you burn a lump of coal let's
say you combine the carbon in it with
the oxygen in the air that's what the
energy comes from and you produce carbon
dioxide co2 now let's let's just spend a
moment on carbon dioxide the air in this
room has point O 3 percent carbon
dioxide in it it's a minor constituent
it's odorless it's colorless it's not
poisonous and it's transparent right
here we are seeing each other
it must be transparent it's transparent
in the visible part of the spectrum the
ordinary kind of light that our eyes are
sensitive to but in the infrared part of
the spectrum the light beyond the red it
is not fully transparent and at a
wavelength like 15 microns it's opaque
if our eyes were good at 15 microns we
could not see our finger in front of our
face which is why our eyes are not good
at 15 microns because that would be
perfectly useless
now what determines the temperature of
the earth visible light comes from the
Sun hits the surface of the earth some
of its reflected back to space the rest
of it it's absorbed by the ground that
goes into heating the earth and what we
have is a kind of equilibrium the earth
radiates to space just the same amount
as what it absorbs from space and that
equilibrium determines the temperature
of the earth but that is only part of
the story the other part has to do with
the greenhouse effect so-called because
of a an imagined analogy to a florist's
greenhouse but the basic idea is that
transparent atmosphere lets the sunlight
in but when the surface tries to radiate
away into space in the infrared that
radiation is impeded by the partially
opaque atmosphere in the infrared carbon
dioxide is one of the causes water vapor
is another ozone chlorofluorocarbons is
a number of molecules that are
greenhouse gases and hold the heat in
now the lifetime of carbon dioxide
molecules in the atmosphere is measured
in thousands of years so every carbon
dioxide molecule we put in the
atmosphere will stay there for the
foreseeable future and increases the
greenhouse effect and therefore
increases the temperature of the earth
globally the worldwide temperature the
curve of carbon dioxide is a function of
time is a kind of increasing sawtooth
like that the the up down is a seasonal
cycle of vegetation on the planet and
the amount of carbon dioxide is
monotonically increasing and has been
doing that for many decades in fact
possibly since the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution it is now entirely
clear that the earth's temperature is
increasing as well globally
at estimated rates of industrial and
domestic use of fossil fuels you can
make some predictions and there's of
course some uncertainty but a typical
prediction is that at the projected
rates of fossil fuel use by the middle
to late 21st century that is roughly a
century from now the global temperature
will have increased sufficiently to make
massive climatic change on the planet
a typical prognostication is the
conversion of the Ukraine and the
American Midwest into something a little
different from scrub deserts that will
have significant economic consequences
but on a timescale that nobody worries
about because it's not our watch it's
our children and grandchildren let them
worry about it on the longer term
there's an even larger catastrophe in
store and that is the collapse of the
West Antarctic Ice Sheet falling into
the Antarctic Ocean raising a sea level
by tens of meters all over the planet
and that means inundating every coastal
city on earth and that's maybe that's a
much less certain prediction the
timescale it's a little like what Lester
was saying about economic forecasting
that it's going to happen is reasonably
clear and when it's going to happen it's
less clear for something like 150 years
from now not maybe before then we will
have figured out alternative energy
sources but because the time scale is so
long for scavenging carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere what we do is
fundamentally irreversible now so this
raises an important question what are
our responsibilities to two three and
four generations from now bearing in
mind that it is extremely unlikely that
there will be a technical
fix to this problem notice the carbon
dioxide does not respect national
boundaries has never heard of national
sovereignty and therefore the burning of
coal in the United States affects the
climate in the Soviet Union and
vice-versa suppose that we were smart
and started limiting the use of fossil
fuels made massive investments in
alternative energy sources solar power
and ultimately fusion power
thermonuclear reactions what would the
consequences be well suppose the United
States and the Soviet Union in 30 years
not out of the question had economically
viable fusion reactors and replaced
their entire fossil fuel economies
despite enormous resistance from fossil
fuel corporations and with that within
everything be fine
everything would not be fine the third
largest coal producer on the planet is
China China is in the throes of massive
industrialization can we imagine the
United States and the Soviet Union going
to China and saying look we know we made
some some mistakes in our
industrialization using fossil fuels but
please learn from our mistake don't you
use coal as well otherwise our farmers
in the Ukraine and the Midwest are going
to be in trouble what's in it for China
I think the United States and the Soviet
Union would have to provide the
alternative power technology at a rate
which was competitive with Chinese use
of coal which will be very cheap in
order to make much of a dent in Chinese
thinking possibly China will be much
more altruistic and planet oriented in
the United States in the Soviet Union
but I wonder if we can bet on that well
this is a kind of
prototype of a generic set of problems
that worldwide technology now brings
before us a set of problems which
involve unanticipated negative
consequences of apparently benign
technology consequences very severe
consequences that are global in nature
and therefore that cannot be solved even
by one or two of the most powerful
industrial nations by themselves
requires the entire industrial world to
to deal with let me give another example
we talked about the visible part of the
spectrum and the infrared long word of
red while going the other way short word
of violet
there's another part of the spectrum
that the Sun puts out that every object
puts out but that our eyes are not
sensitive to called the ultraviolet
ultraviolet light is very dangerous
because the molecules that make us up
especially the nucleic acids and the
proteins fall to pieces or undergo
chemical reactions when it's supposed to
ultraviolet light we ordinarily don't
have to worry about that because we have
an ozone layer ozone is three atoms of
oxygen chemically bond that a kind
Providence has put up 25 kilometers to
40 kilometers in the sky and it absorbs
almost all of that ultraviolet radiation
it's very little ozone however up there
were brought down to this room the
thickness of the ozone layer would be a
quarter of a millimeter thick it's small
and therefore it's vulnerable now in
refrigerants and decreasing Li in
aerosol propellants and as a degradation
product of of some plastic styrofoam and
the like is a molecule set of molecules
called
chlorofluorocarbons CCF's the brand name
of the most widely known is a dupont
brand named freon these molecules have
been chosen precisely because of their
how chemically inert they are no harm if
you breathe them they don't interact
with anything around here it's it sounds
like the ideal kind of by-product for
for some industrial applications but
precisely because they're so inert they
stay around for a long time they get out
into the open air the atmosphere
circulates them and eventually they wind
up high in the atmosphere where they
bump into ozone molecules and ozone is
sufficiently reactive to combine with
the CCF's and fall to pieces well what
is happening is that the ozone is
declining
there is a unpredicted and extremely
worrisome hold of large dimensions in
the Antarctic ozone asphere there are
other holes in the ozone which are
appearing now in Spitsbergen and
elsewhere and it seems very clear that
the production of chlorofluorocarbons is
in the process of compromising the
global ozone layer and the time scale
for these molecules to be scavenged out
of the atmosphere in part by interaction
with ozone is something like a century
so if we stopped right now all ozone all
CCF production a hundred years from now
the consequences would be apparent now
what would happen if there was a
significant decrease in the in Arizona
sphere a superficial consequence which
is what one mainly hears about but it's
by no means the most worrisome is an
increase of skin cancer in people with
lights kittens people with dark skin
are better protected is one of the few
cases where there's a kind of
technological justice the the people who
do the technology carelessly are the
ones who are preferentially destroyed by
it and dark-skinned people who didn't do
it are not bothered by it in most cases
it goes the other way that that the
people who had nothing to do with the
technology of the ones who most suffer
from the negative consequences but much
more important than skin cancer is the
fact that there's a vast range of
microorganisms that are exquisitely
sensitive to increase ultraviolet light
for example the phytoplankton at the
surface of the oceans which are the
primary source of molecular oxygen in
the Earth's atmosphere there is a vast
ecological pyramid you know these guys
harvest sunlight and then these guys eat
those guys and these guys eat those guys
and way up to the top that's us and we
eat them who eat them depend with them
to eat these guys who are sensitive to
ultraviolet light
now this web of interactions is
extremely poorly studied extremely
poorly understood
but I don't think it's it's being
alarmist to say that there's something
to worry about here and to try to deal
with this this issue large number of
industrialized nations
United States and Canada Western Europe
the Soviet Union Japan have been meeting
and have agreed in principle on emission
controls of chlorofluorocarbons there
are special cases Soviet Union and Japan
want some exclusions for periods of time
so it's not to harm their domestic
industry some US corporations have been
very responsible on this issue even if
it involves some loss of profit but this
is another example of an accidental
byproduct of high-technology
that has global venue that involves all
industrialized nations that has possibly
extremely serious consequences and there
are others
acid rain for example radioactivity from
nuclear reactor accidents one very
worrisome aspect though is if you look
how these dangers were uncovered they're
uncovered absolutely accidentally in the
byproduct of some other kinds of
scientific investigation and very late
which suggests that there is probably a
significant category of other serious
global consequences of technology that
we haven't been smart enough to figure
out yet other discoveries along these
lines won't be made in the future we
could even describe some economic
diseases like AIDS as in this category
because they clearly are significantly
assisted by advances in transportation
technology so that the world is to a
significant extent sexually
intercommunicating all and the
exponentiation of a number of AIDS cases
worldwide is now something very serious
because Exponential's beat everything
and this may very well have powerful
consequences in the distribution of
power worldwide for example Soviet Union
in China have disproportionately
extremely small incidents of AIDS
because they are not as sexually into
communicating with the rest of the world
as of many other countries it is
possible that one consequence of the
AIDS epidemic is to leave the Soviet
Union and China in a disproportionately
better-off situation and then the
industrialized West and Japan might have
that might be the single most
significant determinant of the balance
of power among nations on the planet and
not economics not nuclear war not
anything else and who would have figured
that well I want to say a few words
about about the nuclear arms race it is
in a way in this category as well and
one way to look at it is the following
in 1945 just after when Lester began
with Bretton Woods the United States was
the most powerful nation on the planet
not just economically but militarily it
was invulnerable surrounded east and
west by impassable oceans north and
south by weak and friendly neighbors the
United States had absolutely nothing to
worry about in a military sense at least
in terms of direct aggression by other
nations the United States then developed
nuclear weapons and their delivery
systems
has been the leading nation on the
planet and ever increasing the
sophistication of these weapons and the
delivery systems at enormous cost I'll
say something about cost in a moment and
driving I think there's no doubt that
it's American technology that has driven
the nuclear arms race much more than
Soviet technological advances their
Soviets are always in the situation of
huffing and puffing to follow up and try
to match or counter American advances
and the net result is that today the
United States is exquisitely vulnerable
to utter annihilation because of the
very technology that the United States
pioneered in the development nuclear
weapons we are alive United States today
because Soviet leaders did not 20
minutes ago decide to annihilate US and
Soviet citizens are alive today because
20 minutes ago American leaders did not
decide to annihilate them everybody
united states is is vulnerable in
extremely short time skills a fuse 20
minutes long because of this technology
designed to protect ourselves there is a
kind of irony now the nuclear arms race
is so invested with national propaganda
on both sides that of course both sides
have a list as long as your arm of the
abuses by the other and all the reasons
why it's essential to have nuclear
weapons to protect ourselves but the net
result is that nobody is protected and
everybody is vulnerable there are some
60,000 nuclear weapons in the world the
planet has been booby-trapped by the
United States and the Soviet Union of
those 60,000 weapons almost 25,000 our
so-called strategic weapons that is
connected to delivery systems that carry
them from the homeland of one superpower
to the homeland the other superpower and
the remaining 35 30 to 35 thousand
nuclear weapons are so-called tactical
nuclear weapons some of which are
are given demeaning names like munitions
but most of which are more powerful than
the bombs that destroyed Hiroshima and
Nagasaki how many cities are there on
the planet Earth
there's about 2300 cities if you define
a city as having more than a hundred
thousand people that means that the
United States and the Soviet Union if
they wished to cooperate on this matter
by devoting to nuclear weapons to every
city on the planet could destroy every
city on the planet and have twenty
thousand strategic weapons left over as
a challenge to the target ears to figure
out what to use those weapons for I
think it's very clear that no matter
what the function of nuclear weapons are
there are far too many of them in a
so-called central exchange between the
United States and the Soviet Union
estimates of the prompt fatalities that
is in a few days to a few weeks range
from many hundreds of millions to a high
estimate by the World Health
Organization of about two billion people
killed outright and that's mainly from
blast fire prompt radiation and
short-term radioactive fallout there are
a set of longer-term adverse
consequences of nuclear war and let me
just list a few of them there's long
term radioactivity which spreads most of
it hemispheric wide northern hemisphere
that there's a northern mid latitude
target zone where where the greatest
vulnerability is but the radioactivity
spreads north and south of that and some
of it we now know spreads into the
southern hemisphere there is a new and
very incompletely understood consequence
from the burning of modern cities the
production of toxic smaug's you know how
in the burning of a modern
skyscraper people are said to be
overcome by smoke smoke inhalation
that's what it's called that's not what
happens at all what happens is that in
the burning of modern synthetics and
plastics a witch's brew of poison gases
is generated carbon monoxide dioxins
furans and you breathe them and it's
like gas warfare and you you are
poisoned now in the burning of a modern
city those gases all heavy so they stay
near the ground spread out from the city
into the surrounding countryside and
some estimates of how much of that would
occur are are very serious this is not
something that the defense
establishments have discovered and it's
not something that they're interested in
calculating it's all been done by
civilian scientists and then there are a
set of extremely serious climatic
consequences which go into the rubric of
nuclear winter which is essentially a
blocking of sunlight for periods between
weeks and perhaps years lowering of
temperatures 10 to 20 degrees centigrade
change in the in the average temperature
of the planet are what the range of
modern calculations for a nuclear war
that involves about a third of the
strategic Arsenal's the average
temperature this difference between now
and the last ice age is 10 degrees
centigrade so we're talking about very
serious temperature changes the most
significant adverse consequences of
nuclear winter is is in agriculture the
destruction of crops for example
Canadian wheat and barley production is
brought to zero by a three degree
centigrade temperature decline and it is
estimated that from this source alone
starvation for
several billion people as is likely
there are also a range of synergism z'
that is cases where the some of the
advert where the net adverse consequence
is more than the sum of the individual
adverse consequences and let me give
just one example of how that would work
the prompt effects of the nuclear war
destroy doctors and hospitals who are
preferentially in the target zones and
and in the cities the destruction of
civil and sanitary facilities promotes
the development of disease birds are
preferentially killed by lowering
temperatures and the radiation they are
a significant source of control of
insects which are disease vectors so the
birds aren't there the disease carriers
proliferate medical facilities are
unavailable and radiation levels that
aren't enough to kill you are enough to
significantly lower your immunity to
disease and one of the consequences of
the sub-lethal radiation in a nuclear
war even in places far from target zones
is something like a global case of AIDS
that is I mean you don't have to do
anything special to get it except be
complacent about the nuclear arms race
but what happens is your ability to
resist disease is compromised at
precisely the time when diseases are
rampaging that's an example of synergism
well it can be argued that these
consequences are so severe that we of
course would not would not permit this
to happen and that great safeguards are
taken to prevent
accidental nuclear war inadvertent
nuclear war but I think we only have to
go back two years to two spectacular
technological catastrophes of the two
superpowers to see how bankrupt this
argument is I'm talking about Challenger
and Chernobyl here we have high
technologies in which enormous amounts
of national prestige have been invested
by the United States in the Soviet Union
and which nevertheless spectacularly
fail
there are many ironies here one of which
is a year before Chernobyl an interview
with the Soviet deputy minister of heavy
industry or something was published in
the Soviet english-language magazine
Soviet life in which this guy by bad
luck picked on Chernobyl as an example
of the safety of Soviet fission reactors
and estimated she said had been
carefully done that the average time to
catastrophic failure for the Chernobyl
nuclear plant would be a hundred
thousand years that's how long you'd
have to wait before there was a serious
accident that Chernobyl and he was
pointing to this as an example of the
safety of Soviet nuclear power
facilities one year later kaboom and
likewise for the for the Challenger
Space Shuttle disaster in which seven
astronauts lost their lives both NASA
and contractor spokespersons had said
less than a year before the Charlie
Challenger disaster that the average
time to spectacular failure would be
10,000 years now these aren't just any
old technologies these are technologies
which are important for the public
images in the United States and the
Soviet Union where there isn't anything
like the secrecy involved that there
isn't a nuclear arms race and therefore
the opportunity for vigorous criticism
is much larger than in
compartmentalised secret environment
such as involves nuclear weapons for
these and similar reasons the claim that
yes we have an extremely dangerous
technology but don't worry we have
absolutely impassable safeguards should
be greeted with some significant
skepticism in my view and then beyond
that there is the evident fact evident
in the century of Hitler and Stalin that
madmen can achieve the highest the
highest offices in modern industrial
nations and in fact I think it is
apparent even from recent history of
many nations that the the psychological
screening for highest officials is not
what it might be
and therefore it must be only a matter
of time it's very clear for example that
in 1944 and 45 if Hitler had nuclear
weapons and the lies had nuclear weapons
and Hitler was it was guaranteed to
Hitler that if Hitler used nuclear
weapons that Germany would be destroyed
that nevertheless Hitler would have used
nuclear weapons in fact Hitler was as
angry at the German people for not doing
some superhuman effort to to deflect the
Allied invasion as he wasn't the
Alliance he wanted the German people to
be punished and that kind of psychology
in a national leader with nuclear
weapons is something I believe to be
worried about so the nuclear arms race
is something supremely foolish that we
have done always for patriotic reasons
always thinking the short term and
ignoring the long term is a a kind of
machine that goes by itself each side's
escalation prompts the other side to
escalate and is capable certainly of
obliterating the United States in the
Soviet Union and Western Europe Eastern
Europe China Japan Canada that's of
course not the whole planet but for
those of us who live in those countries
and even for a few others that that
would be a significant loss nuclear war
would very likely destroy the global
civilization and conceivably although
this is much less certain could end the
few million year old experiment human
experiment on the planet Earth stakes
are never higher
here is an example of a technology that
that in dangers everybody on the planet
and yes there are some stirrings we will
if all goes well next month have a three
percent reduction in those sixty
thousand nuclear weapons on the planet
it's at least a step in the right
direction but at the same time the
United States and the Soviet Union will
be building more nuclear weapons than
those taken away in the INF treaty both
nations built something like two or
three net new nuclear weapons every day
and this is going to take some doing to
undo the nuclear arms race in my view
what is needed is to bring it down at
least to a kind of minimum deterrence in
which each side retains an invulnerable
capability to annihilate the other but
not enough to destroy the global
civilization that seems to me
minimal prudence I think there's a
significant chance I don't know what it
is it's certainly not as high as 50% of
doing that
but it's certainly not going to be easy
now I want to say something about about
cost of the nuclear arms race and indeed
of of armaments in general the world
spends every year one trillion dollars
on augments the United States and the
Soviet Union vie with each other for the
privilege of selling of the most arms to
other usually developing nations and
this money I think an extraterrestrial
observer might believe is not being used
in the most efficient way for human
betterment
we could ask another question how much
money is the United States spent on the
Cold War since 1945 now I'm not for a
moment arguing that there aren't real
reasons to have significant improve
National Defense but I think a case can
be made that you could do that with
significantly less money than has
actually been spent how much money has
been spent by the time the Reagan
administration leaves office in January
1989 or conceivably earlier the total
amount in 1987 dollars will have been
spent on the on the Cold War is ten
trillion dollars by the United States
what could you buy for 10 jillion
dollars the answer is you could buy
everything everything in the United
States except the land nuclear purchase
for 10 trillion dollars highways
skyscrapers ships boats airplanes cars
school rooms baby diapers everything so
it seems to me that does raise the
question of has this been the most
effective use of our money and likewise
has it been the most effective use of
the comparable Soviet expenditures in
addition to the question of the amount
of money spent on this there's the
question of the deflection of scientific
and engineering talent away from the
civilian economy more than half the
scientists and technologists on the
planet today are employed by the various
military establishments what would
happen if a significant fraction of them
were pried loose to develop other kinds
of technology that might be a little
more beneficial as Lester mentioned the
United States has gone within the last
few years from being the largest
creditor to the largest debtor nation on
the planet the national debt is not only
larger than that of any previous
administration it is larger than the sum
of all previous administrations back to
George Washington
since 1980 the annual increase in the
budget deficit is almost exactly the
annual increase in military expenditures
I am very far from understanding
anything about economics but it occurs
to me that these two facts may be
connected I also wonder if the boom in
the German and Japanese economies might
have something to do with the fact that
there are military budgets as a fraction
of gross national product I've been
extremely low because of the United
States supplying a significant amount of
their defense and concern by other
nations that in Japanese in German
rearmament in the light of world war 2
may be undesirable there is a sense in
which and this may be too strong I'll
say it anyway in which the United States
is showing signs of being a kind of
developing nation it is 17th in the
world in infant mortality a quarter of
the population is functionally
illiterate high school students all over
the United States cannot locate the
United States on an unmarked world map
have no idea where their own country is
I saw one
one excursion of this sort where where a
student asked to identify where the
Soviet Union was pointed to Nicaragua
this may be a consequence of the success
of the president's propaganda but it is
geographically incompetent patent
applications are steeply done there are
evident homeless people in every major
city 20 million people in the United
States are hungry every day that
skip one or more meal because they can't
afford it
there are half as many graduate degrees
in science and technology every year in
the United States than in Japan which
has half the American population public
transportation and urban infrastructure
in general are disgrace by say European
standards there are lacks environmental
standards in some respects United States
is one of the most backward nations on
the planet in dealing with its
technological waste and the kind of
decisions which are in effect made are
that we need the job so desperately that
we will sacrifice of the health of
someone astuteness citizens united
states is 14th in the world in percent
of the population with safe water now
all of these things are connected with
money you could solve these problems in
the United States if there were more
money available to do it why is that
money not available it seems to me it is
very clear that one of the chief reasons
it's not available both of the direct
cents and in the indirect sense of what
those scientists and technologists could
do if they weren't working for the
military is the military budget and any
attempt to emerge from the global
economic crisis which Lester has
outlined seems to me and I claim those
significant expertise here to have to
deal with the question of the massive
military budgets of the United States
and the Soviet Union
and indeed in the developing world as
well this has clearly been recognized by
mr. Gorbachev who makes it clear that
one of the reasons he's interested in
both nuclear and conventional arms
reduction treaty z' is to free up some
of the military sector of the
Soviet economy for civilian uses and to
do that there are changes needed in in
the openness in the society and the
freedoms which are given to citizens
very hard to to do significant
pioneering science and technology in a
society in which you are not permitted
to make public criticism criticism is
the lifeblood
scientific method and so from economic
necessity freedom is at least in limited
to unknown at extent is driven and
precisely the same thing is is true in
China and the statements been explicitly
made by Deng Xiaoping we I guess what
I'm saying is the definition of national
security
involves more than how many weapons you
have in fact in terms of nuclear weapons
there is certainly a point in which the
more nuclear weapons you have the less
safe you are as I was trying to argue
before there's a kind of
counterintuitive aspect of modern
technology in the military and in the
civilian spheres and there is a
necessity after 1945 of what Einstein
called a new way of thinking which is
very slowly permeating into the minds of
leaders on the question of the
definition of national defense I'd like
to read to you a one sentence quote from
Dwight Eisenhower the problem in defense
spending is to figure how far you should
go without destroying from within what
you are trying to defend from without
and any definition of national security
it seems to me has to involve the
well-being of the citizens economic
well-being a positive sense of the
future based not on path but on
real expectations education especially
in science and technology the scientific
illiteracy of Americans in general is
scandalous every day there are
significant decisions made in Washington
involving science and technology which
have very long outreach into the future
and 435 members of Congress there are
perhaps two who in any sense have a
scientific or technological background
the office of the president's science
advisor has been downgraded in recent
years the president's scientific
advisory committee was cancelled in the
Nixon administration because it gave
advice that was politically undesired
the laws of physics did not correspond
adequately enough to the ideological
wishes of the leadership and no
subsequent president has thought it
advisable to resuscitate the president
Science Advisory Committee for a nation
which is in many significant respects
dependent upon Science and Technology to
arrange things that nobody knows
anything about science and technology is
clearly suicidal and some of the
problems that I've been mentioning
before are connected to this how is it
we didn't foresee the consequences of
many of these technologies it's because
there's a very small science and
technology base in in the United States
there's a small science and technology
base in the Soviet Union as well but
they're doing a lot more in scientific
technological education then we are how
much science and technology do you see
for example in the mass media every
newspaper in America has a daily
astrology column
how many have even a weekly science
column why is this
how much science do you see on
television when somebody wins the Nobel
Prize do you ever get a coherent
explanation of what he wanted for what
was this discovery that was important
enough doing a Nobel Prize well the the
basic sense in television is that the
American people are too stupid to
understand and that it takes
concentration and therefore in the quest
for small differential advantage in a
competition between the networks that it
will be a means of losing ratings to
spend time explaining what science is
about short term advantage for the
network long term disaster
OMG well I have just one concluding
remark and that is that I know I've been
slightly negative in this presentation
there is not the slightest doubt that
science and technology but in particular
the scientific way of thinking can be
used in a very significant way to turn
around many of these problems and to
work for human betterment but it
requires a break with the idea that
everything we've done in the past is
okay and any criticism of it is as
impermissible that so many people for
example of both political parties and in
fact in the United States and the Soviet
Union have invested their entire careers
on the advisability of the nuclear arms
race that that already means that there
is a vast vested interest in turning
things around and this is true in many
of the other technological areas that I
mentioned in order to justify a lifetime
of some ambulance on the critical issues
people are reluctant to even have those
critical issues addressed so what I
think is most urgently needed in all
aspects of life the United States and
the Soviet Union and elsewhere is a
comprehensive baloney detection kit in
which the average citizen can treat with
appropriate skepticism remarks made by
high government officials and those
justifying the continuance of the way
we've always done things whatever those
things are I think good widespread
critical thinking is an essential
precondition for the higher standards of
leadership that we desperately need and
for the higher standards of education
and awareness of problems we face which
i think is required of every citizen
thank you very much Clausen car
[Applause]